we found out that Ronnie the limo driver
does poetry did he ever write a play
know that he showed me something
yesterday or the day before and he said
it's almost done I don't know that was
like that was probably Monday I don't
know where we are I'm really looking
forward to hearing his poetry are you
working on I gained lots of [ __ ] here's
my [ __ ] righty-o are you are you working
on a poem with you are you working on a
poem yeah Oh what is that happening it's
it's it's done yeah it's done
oh it's done but I'm not gonna I'm not
reading it somebody else gone what is it
a love poem let me hear it
you read it no you read it I don't want
to read it all right bring it in let me
read it all right you probably can't
read his trick in scratch yeah but then
you had water I wrote it in iambic
pentameter telling this guy advisor I
think in pink crayon okay it's called
winter right that's the topic you gave
him - the topic member you were
complaining about winter yeah Ronnie
wodsworth plant I don't swear to God I
swear I wrote that dude I swear to God I
swear to God my kids my everything Rita
JD read it like it's supposed to be read
play winter
[Laughter]
is that ridiculous leaves on the trees
don't make him nervous co-ed don't make
them nervous
have fun winter is when there are no
leaves on the trees winter is when we
get an extra hour of ZZZ winter is when
a red-suited man brings us all lots of
you might see employer old you left the
word off winter is when a red-suited man
brings us all lots of Glee yeah ok you
really ruined it yeah winter is when the
snow falls and we and we yell happy new
year just like a laundry list of what
you could do in the oh right come on now
winter is when you turn to a special
girl on a girl or guy
I can't [ __ ] ass alright a little
better oh my god go ahead finish it what
there is when you turn that special girl
or guy's heart bright red with love and
cheer until this time again next dear
big pale winter comes after Ottoman
before spring good last paragraph winter
goes away and the birds and the bees and
the leaves on the tree I'll go back to
where they should be
winter spring pretty good man
beautifully should make that into a song
winter spring okay get it [ __ ]
probably getting brought back that whole
thing about getting seized that was a
reprieve and like and JD those are
stanzas that's a poem yeah well sorry
I'm not I'm not the point here Ronnie is
alright thank you you go sit in the car
and wait for me